I want to welcome you all to a new event and a new topic, or rather two topics, which is persona and groups and Jung's ideas and concepts behind it and all the interesting things he said about it.
This is an interesting event and topic to talk about because mostly what Jung talks about and what people know about Jung are these, let's say, inner world topics of dreams, hallucinations, psychology, personality. Those are all the things that happen inside the person.
But Jung also talked extensively about the things of the external world, the outside world, and how people interact with that. And his gateway, psychological gateway from the internal to the external, And, and to the outside world is the persona.
And the persona is coming from a theater, ancient Greek and Latin theater, meaning that in the past when you had the actors at theater playing, they were always wearing a mask. And this mask was called persona, but the reason why it was called persona is very interesting.
Because in it there was a little mouthpiece like a pipe, and this was used to amplify the voice of the actors because back then, no PA systems, no microphones. They had to use all the tricks to create some acoustic to really give a lot of people the chance to hear clearly what the actors are saying, what is happening on stage.
So people have this mask, people have that pipe, and they were talking through the pipe. And persona consists of two words, Latin words, per sonare, so through sound.
And this became associated with a mask, persona, and now Jung uses it to describe how we interact in groups and with the outside world and other people. We would call it today maybe more a role or function. And Jung uses the word persona or mask.
So I said already, this is our function, how we interact with the outside world. And there's a kind of equivalent because there's always an equivalent and opposite for Jung.
So for Jung, our access to the collective unconscious, which is the unconscious of our human nature or like psychology, uh, of the past is our soul image, the anima, the animus, which is kind of a threshold guardian and the access to that psychological sphere.
We also have this to the outside world, which is then the persona, and it is the outside world rather interacting with our persona. Than directly with ourselves as mostly how we are established in the outside world through our persona, not our own complete personality and being.
So this basically means when you don't have a persona, you don't really have access to the outside world. And Jung describes it like that. You're presenting yourself and are also perceived from the outside world, from society, from other persons in a reduced manner.
You're presenting yourself in a reduced manner and you're also perceived in a reduced manner. So when you, for example, meet a cashier at the supermarket, you're interacting rather with the function and the role of the cashier than with the complete person. And if somebody is asking you how you're doing, how are things going?
Very often people are so polite to not roll out all of the drama and trauma that they have and dump it on unsuspecting bystanders. But they say, ah, it's fine. It's good. Oh, I'm not feeling so well. So it's rather short and concise. So it's a sign of politeness to have a persona and it's a necessity.
For working together with other people in a good way, because there's a lot hiding behind the persona, but the persona makes it easy to interact with other people. So this also means when there are no people around, there's no need for a persona. So if you're alone on an island, you can do what you want, you can behave what you want.
And many people do that in their own apartments. They start singing, talking to themselves. This is all this or dancing for no reason. So this is all the behavior that you would not do in public because people would be rather concerned what other people would think about them.
So, and this would mean when you don't have a persona that you don't really care about what other people think. So when you have, for example, people that have a mental breakdown or psychotic episode, there's also no persona.
There's no way for outside people to interact with them, but they also don't have really a way to interact with other people at this very moment.
So the persona is a kind of compromise between oneself as a complex individual that one is and the rather outside world, which does not have, let's say, the bandwidth, capacity, or time to interact with a complete human being with all the complexity, with all the nuances, but rather to have it condensed down to something specific.
It's a little bit when you have, for example, a lake. Now it's winter and you have the cold air between the cold air and the lake. There will form, when temperature drops low enough, a film thin of ice. And this will kind of separate the both.
And this is also how the persona forms as just a function of individuals interacting with other people and with groups. The persona is generated all by itself through the interactions, through both things.
So I said people can use this persona to only talk about the good things about oneself to impress other people. So this is But social media is, for example, LinkedIn is a perfect example. You're crafting a persona.
You're saying all the things that are great about you, all the things you can do in hopes to garner attention from a potential employer or find people or business contacts on LinkedIn. This is fostering the persona. This is the active part that one gives into there. But on the flip side, there's also the expectations of society.
Just of you existing there, automatically certain expectations coming up. Just as, let's say it's the Titanic and it's going down, the expectation is that the women and the children go first and the men wait when it's about the rescue boats.
So when people know that you are a doctor or suspect that they are a doctor, they will automatically treat you differently because in the mind there is this persona, there's this function, this role that people will automatically assume about you.
So on the one side, of course, you can foster certain things, but on the other side, there's this automatic, let's say, projection expectations about you that you also cannot escape.
So the persona is not something completely inside of us, but it's something outside of us, which is, as I said, a compromise between the individual with its demands, hopes, dreams, and so on, and the society with its expectations.
So when we talk about the outside world, the outside world consists of objects, and oneself as a subject becomes an object just by being in the outside world of others. So there is a certain degree of control that one has about one's persona, but once it's out, it's pretty much out.
And this is very often how, for example, hit pieces in the media work, that you talk about a certain person to craft a certain image about that person and attach it to that to, for example, get it kicked off from social media or out of the job or something like that. This is strategy that we see today pretty often.
And this is what I mean with the persona is not necessarily within oneself, but rather something outside oneself. I guess what makes it a lot different in comparison to, for example, to the anima or animus is that the persona itself does not have any psychology or own agenda or something. It's rather this inanimate mask that one wears or has to wear.
So there's not much more complexity more than that. And the persona has certain pitfalls associated with it in the sense that it's also very easy to hide behind a persona. So as I already established, there's a narrow bandwidth that people have to interact with each other.
When it's a cashier, it's just a couple of seconds. And of course, this can be used to, let's say, pretend. So I remember many years ago, there was this movement of the pickup artists, so that really tried to craft their personality, their interests, how they looked, how they acted to get into bed. With women very easily.
So they were basically just crafting their persona and also trying to hide behind it to say like, oh, I'm, I'm so uninteresting. I have to craft something to get the opposite sex interested in me. And this is a pitfall that Jung said, especially men can fall into. So when men get a certain status.
And are in a functioning group or society, they have a role associated with it. They're maybe even promoted. They are boss, leader, something like that. They have achievements. So it's easy then to say, okay, I will just feel at home in my persona and ignore everything else about my personality and hide just behind that.
So I'm just constantly fostering that LinkedIn profile and make myself interesting on post. All the nice vacation pictures on Facebook, Instagram, and all the other social media platforms. So that the focus on the persona, on crafting the outside image, takes away the attention and care of the inner psychology, the inner world. Carl Gustav Jung is always the same.
When you focus on one thing, you disregard the other thing. And he says the same way, if you only focus on your anima or your animus, you're so focused inwardly that you do not really have something on the outside much to show. Also might seem rather weird.
So it's easy for compensation to feel oneself better by hiding behind the persona. But of course, this is not a really valid strategy for life because as Jung always says, when you focus on one thing, too much, on the other side, there will come a compensation and will try to get one back into the center.
And this is blindness to the inner world where Jung sees the danger always of, let's say, the outside world. If you're only entangled in the outside world and you're only focused on that, and he said there's a problem for extraverted people, then all the background stuff is still happening. You're just not noticing it.
So this describes the persona part, how a person interacts with the outside world. But what you also have in the outside world is a lot of human beings that if you bundle them together, you get groups. And groups is a second topic.
As Carl Gustav Jung talked a lot, really, about different types of psychology. He talks about developmental psychology, differential psychology, and this is now group psychology. And for those people who are familiar with all the things that Jung talked about, it's very individual-focused. And, and also when he talks about groups, he's very focused on individuals.
So Jung is critical of groups because there are certain things that happen when psyche once you're in a group instead of a singular person. And he said groups are very often a kind of refuge for the individual.
This means it's very easy to hide in a group so that you don't have to develop yourself, but rather just conform to the group and everything is fine, that you've then been taken care of. It's on one side, of course, a place for loneliness, but also a place of hiding away from responsibility.
And he called it really to have like the loudness or the sound of the fire to disperse all the negative feelings and things people don't want to deal with. This is analog to some still pagan rituals that we have in the modern world.
For example, when you have New Year's Eve, or we have it also in Germany in the spring, or with Halloween, where you try to make a lot of noise, a lot of sound, a lot of fire to chase away the devils and the bad ghosts. So similar thing happens in a group because a group is loud, things are constantly happening, there are stimuli.
So this distracts from the inner needs. And the inner responsibility. This is a danger of groups in general.
And what happens then for Jung is because they're taking away the attention from the inner and from developing the own consciousness, this means that in a group psychology, it condenses down to the most common denominator.
This means a group, even though that it consists of several, let's say, complex individuals, as a group, they are less complex. An example would be when you have two people talking with each other, you can have a whole conversation. You can have it for hours. You can talk about different points. You can argue, you can differentiate, and so on.
This becomes way harder when you try to interact with a group. For example, in a concert where this whole complexity that you can have between two people boils down in a group to basically yay and nay and boo and some basic sounds, not really allowing for the complexity of exchange.
So in a concert, that's perfectly fine because there's not much for the group to do than to experience the music. Listening to the music. But this becomes, of course, more difficult when you have something, for example, like a mob, a group of people that are, let's say, possessed by a, by a common spirit.
And this is, if we look at the psychological model that Jung had of the psyche, where we have all, we have our consciousness, we have our personal unconscious. And we have our collective unconscious and all these things. The, the lower you go, the more archaic things you find.
And similar as a group, the bigger the group gets, the ideas and the concepts that are able to move the group get more and more archaic and simpler. And this goes then down to basically emotions. So when you have a group that's in panic, you have a stampede. So many years ago, we had this tragedy at the Love Parade.
It was in Duisburg, where, yeah, a huge group wanted to go onto, to the Love Parade, but the area was full.
So they just closed the gate and people just accumulated, got tighter, tighter, tighter, and then they found a a single staircase out, so people tried to leave through that, but the whole group saw it, started pushing, people got into panic and people died because you then have a huge herd of people getting into panic, getting into stampede.
In that sense, groups are not so different from animals. Similar when you have a mob, like a riot, there's a emotion taking over people and suddenly People are starting doing things they would never do alone.
Like a singular sane person would not start a riot, but if you have multiple people together, suddenly this threshold gets lower and lower. And you see that, for example, adolescent boys, like when you have single ones, they might be, let's say, for themselves, they might be more agreeable.
Might less do stupid stuff in contrast when they're in the group where all this encouragement takes place and all these dynamics come into place. But suddenly people get, let's say, braver in groups and do things they would never do on their own. So Jung really repeats this very often.
You can take 100 people in a group, as a group, then they are pretty dumb. It's a lowering of consciousness and a lowering of complexity. And all the individuality that you have for the people themselves all gets mushed together in a group, similar as when you have watercolors and you mix them together. In the end, everything is brown.
It doesn't matter all the wonderful colors you had. In the end, it's one brown mass. And this has to do with how people influence each other. And this is, for Jung, unsurprisingly, in a big part unconsciously. So how do people interact?
How do people influence each other? And it's very often through the unconscious. This means when I have a strong emotion right now, hatred, joy, fear, whatever. Very likely this will go over to the surrounding people around me also.
So this is why it's easier to laugh in a comedy club or when you see a comedy in the movie theater than when you watch it at home. It's infectious. To have emotions and affects that they go then to, to other people and infect them and bringing them to the same level.
And the bigger the group, the stronger this chain reaction gets and the more it just sways people and drives it up into a frenzy. And Jung has a certain word for that. When things are there in the unconscious of the individual, and he calls that constellating.
This means something in the person is activated, like an emotion or also an archetype. This means there are these background patterns of behavior somewhere deep in the psyche, in the collective unconscious. It's instincts, it's emotions, it's archetypes. And when the situation is right, they are brought forward.
So this is why religious experiences can be way more fun when you do it with other people, right? Or music concert is just completely different. Or a sports event. Yes, you can watch it at home or you can even watch it in a bar. It's already way better than watching it alone. And when you're in the stadium, you have the sound and the smell and everything.
And this huge group of people experiences the same thing at the same time. It's intoxicating. It sways people away and people travel to get this feeling. People take time off work. They pay a lot of money. They travel all over the world just to have then this experience with others to get swayed away.
And this he calls constellation and has certain contents constellated. So for Jung, the unconscious consists already of autonomous psychic forces, but our unconscious is very similar to unconscious of other people.
So what affects me also likely affects other people pretty easily when it's on a low enough level. So another point why the, let's say, conscious level of groups goes lower when you get more and more people.
Another disadvantage, and I mentioned it before, the slow bandwidth to communicate with a group, to get, to talk to them, but also to get feedback. At that point, he said, that's also why it's not possible to preach to groups or to educate groups. That's not really possible. If that had been possible, it would have happened already thousands or tens of thousands of years ago.
It comes always back to the individual, the individual being part of the group. So while you can't talk to a group, you can talk to an individual in the group and you can interact with them and further them in their development. So he sees that really as a key thing in context of groups.
When you want to have a functioning group, You need functioning individuals that take responsibility and take care of themselves and ideally are not swept by the emotion and all the constellated contents that are in the collective unconscious of the group, since every group also has a kind of group unconscious that can potentially wreak havoc.
So when he said the individual can be moral, the group cannot really be until the individuals in the group are moral. The individuals can achieve something in the group, but if you want the group something to achieve, you need more of that.
So he really saw groups as a potential breeding ground for evil because all these archaic things can come up in a archaic, undifferentiated, unsophisticated manner. So development is talking to people directly, singular people, fostering the relationships.
And the same way as it can be negative that people are influenced negatively through these emotions, they can also be influenced positively. You notice that how people influence each other. He uses this term very often used in hunter-gatherer societies called mana. There's a certain charisma about somebody.
And he very often associates that with the, let's say, I don't want to say higher consciousness, but more differentiated, more well-rounded consciousness that people can feel, oh, there's somebody there that has experience, knowledge. That I might not have.
And this causes a kind of looking up, but also imitation of that person, which can create then of course a positive feedback loop for groups since people then can orient towards that.
But all in all, this can all fall flat if people go into a group just to be unconscious and live only in the psychology of the group. This can happen in families.
He saw that very often when people stay in an infantile mental state of mind where they just exist through the relationships around them, mainly siblings, the parents, or the children, where there's not personal responsibility taking place and personal development, but rather being entangled everywhere else.
So people don't have to deal with their own problems, running away. The antidote that Carl Gustav Jung saw for such behavior of kind of devolving of groups and automatic devolving into a more archaic state, he saw in culture.
Culture meaning giving people a way to manifest positively archetypes. So archetypes are always there. They're always in the collective unconscious. They come out all by themselves, activated by certain situations.
But the question is how they then manifested and how they are provided a ground to be productive. And to be in a positive form. Let's say aggression. This is an example which I use very often. Like, everybody knows what aggression is. Everybody has felt aggression. Aggression will always be there.
The question is how you channel it. So there are certain times when aggression is a very good thing and a useful thing if used in the right way. For example, in sports, when you're playing football, you should find a way to be aggressive. Or if you're a policeman, you should be able to have a certain control about your aggressiveness to push into certain directions.
That does not mean to immediately hurt people, but rather to channel it in kind of one appears or one talks, the action one does. And this is similar with the archetypes. So These are ancient.
These are always been with humanity because it's situations that happen so often that they become part of a priori human psychology when a new human is born, but they can manifest in different ways. And for Jung, is culture, or let's say cultural experience, the treasure trove of a society.
As on how to manifest archetypal behavior in a good and positive manner. Because when you get lost in the group, you can get swept away. And this is what he really sees as a problem for the modern time.
As modernity and humanity progresses, The groups get bigger, bigger, bigger, and bigger. On the one side, of course, we have more human beings, but also we have more ways of organizing and living together in bigger and bigger groups.
So he saw the, uh, problem of the 20th century really of that, of big groups and states that are millions and millions of people where just the individual completely disappears.
And where people get then swept away by ancient archaic ideas or emotions that manifest in paths and isms. So Jung was against all the isms, fascism, communism, all different ways where it said, okay, there's an idea-driven group behavior.
He has said, it's a famous quote, that people don't have ideas, but ideas have people. It's then really that an idea takes over the psychology of a group and then of course the individuals and brings them up into a frenzy.
And he saw that, he saw that with the First World War, with the Second World War, where the tone immediately became different once it became clear that there would be war and suddenly people were doing things that they otherwise would have not done.
But it's then all the group pressure happening in the background, which does not have to be orchestrated by someone by necessity, but it's something that is just an inherent quality of groups.
And so of course this can be negatively influenced by people who really set out to instill certain ideas in groups, but that does not necessarily mean just because a group does something that there's somebody who consciously did all these things, but rather it's a huge unconscious group doing something by basically design.
So there's a huge relationship between the problems of an individual and a problem of the group. So while it sounds like, okay, you have a group, the individual is not important, the problem of the individual becomes the problem of the group. Similar as the problem of the individual reflects the problem of the times that the individual lives in.
So in the same way to, let's say, heal the group is necessary to Have the individual and foster the individual through direct relationships to then in turn create a positive feedback loop in groups.
This might have sounded all very negative in context of groups.
Jung says there are, of course, huge benefits and there's a necessity, uh, about it, but He always feared because he also saw that, that people might take the easy way out to personal problems, that they get entangled with the, with the wrong things, not dealing with the own problem that they have, but rather to find a kind of other outlet to distract themselves, to not pay attention to the things that are painful to pay attention with, with.
One's individual shadow or even the shadow of, of a society, the things that a society does not want to deal with, but then in turn is of course again something that is very likely a problem of the individual. It's a back and forth relationship.
So yeah, Jung's view on modernity was negative because of the big groups and the big states and the big governments and the, uh, big companies. And this is the view from basically 100 years ago. It's become way more extreme today.
We have now even bigger groups and even more people under one umbrella where the individuality he fears is diminished to a large point because he says when you have a state or you have a government, It's only interested in, let's say, citizens.
It's more interested in the masks and the personas that people fulfill a certain function, but not really interested in the individual. So he says, on the one side, you have nature, which is also kind of unforgiving and does not care about the individual. Then you have society, the states, the governments.
That also might not be interested, or let's say very likely interested in fostering the individual with the individual problems, but rather concerned with the creation of a Mass Man, because that's what he saw. He saw this completely and experienced change into modernity, industrializations, huge mass fabrications of things.
And binding together of people. And so here he saw the main problem of modernity, that it's not necessarily the lack of material goods or safety or security.
So all the things that, um, were of a problem in the past, he said the problems of today are rather, uh, psychological in nature. And it's rather these psychic epidemics, as he called them, that would sweep away huge groups and bring them to do horrible things like the fascists did and the communists did.
And this is the greatest danger of humanity at that time. And he was especially unhappy with, let's say, the, the trust in government and the, let's say, relationship of what's expected.
He said like the people are the government, but at the same time they're expecting from the state and the government all these things that they're not necessarily able to do themselves. He said this is not really a healthy way to look at it, and he was very critical about it. But he was also Swiss.
So of course he was critical about big countries, big groups, and also big government. Yeah, this would conclude my talk about these two concepts about persona and groups. And I want to thank you for listening and I hope you learned something.